JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Hey, everyone.
I'm John McCutchan.
You might remember me
from a couple hours ago.
But instead of games, I'm
here to talk about Dart.
I'm an engineer on
the Dart VM team.
And the goal of the
team that I'm on
is to really make
the web faster.
Our goal is to make applications
run at least twice as
fast as they can in JavaScript.
But this talk is going to focus
a lot on like what Dart is,
and its philosophy, and
the feel of the language.
But before I start, how many
of you have heard of Dart?
And how many of you
have tried out Dart?
Taken a look at it?
All right, well, I hope
to change some minds here.
So I guess you could capture
a lot of Dart's philosophy
with this phrase
"batteries included,"
which in America
means, like it comes
with everything
you need to use it.
So Dart-- it's not
just a language,
but there's actually
standard libraries.
There's tools, an editor that
understands the code base,
can give you
auto-completion, everything.
There's a virtual machine.
That's the team that
I work on, and that's
headed by Lars Bach,
who used to do V8.
You might know V8.
And then there's a
compiler to JavaScript.
So even if your browser doesn't
have the Dart virtual machine,
it doesn't matter, because
you can compile Dart source
code to JavaScript, and
it runs just as fast
as handwritten JavaScript.
And you'll see the
compelling reasons
of why you might want to code
in Dart versus pure JavaScript.
So here's a little story here.
So I want to build
a web app, right?
This is the state
of the world today
if you're a
JavaScript developer.
Well, you'll get to Backbone,
and backbone Marionette,
and jQuery, and
Modernizr-- I mean,
it just goes on and on and on.
It's kind of crazy, right?
I mean, there's
no standard stack.
There's no default
way that everyone
who's writing JavaScript
writes JavaScript.
Every JavaScript project
kind of hand-picks
a few of these libraries, that
they like, and goes with it.
But Dart has all of
these things included.
So there's a little
bit of sanity here.
Things are very consistent.
So the Dart SDK
is the base here.
And then what we have is
we have a package system
where Dart library developers
can upload their packages
to a central repository.
And then you, as a Dart
programmer, can just say,
well, I want to use
the unit test library,
and I want to use
Web UI, and I care
about internationalization, and
you'll just get those packages.
And every other Dart
programmer out there
is going to be using
these same packages,
so there's a little
bit of consistency.
But then we want to
scale web apps up.
Right now, it's very difficult
even inside of Google.
I mean, we've got
dozens-- no, hundreds
of engineers working in
millions of lines of code.
There's all these
different layers.
There's GWT, there's
Closure, there's Soy.
But the productivity is impacted
by this, because there's
no edit/refresh iteration
cycle during development.
You have to go through all these
different intermediate steps
just to see the
change that you made,
and the source code actually
show up on the site.
So this is kind of like a
running theme here with Dart,
is that we can do
better than this.
And there's a lot of
competition in terms
of languages to
replace JavaScript.
And in a way, that confirms
one of Dart's goals, which
is that JavaScript
has certain flaws,
and there's a lot of
languages out there
that are trying to kind
of paper over these flaws,
and make it easier
and more digestible.
So there's Dart,
there's Closure,
there's CoffeeScript there's
TypeScript there's GWT.
But when you compare
all of these things,
Dart has some really
compelling things--
in particular the rightmost
column here, performance.
These other languages
are always built
around the idea of compiling
directly to JavaScript,
so the performance is
kind of like however
fast you can run
JavaScript, that's
how fast your program written
in CoffeeScript or Typescript
can run.
It can't run any quicker.
But with Dart,
with a Dart VM, you
could theoretically
run twice as fast.
So let's give a
quick tour of what
Dart source code looks like.
So Dart is class-based.
It's object-oriented.
It's not prototype based
the way JavaScript is.
So the one running theme
with Dart source code
is that it's familiar.
If you're familiar with a
language like Java or C or C++
or C#, you're going to feel
right at home with Dart.
It's very similar.
So let's make a class Hug.
And Hug can have
a strength to it.
How strong am I hugging you?
But you can be really terse.
A lot of the time, in your
constructor for a class,
you open it up, and you just
take the parameters that
were passed to the
constructor, and assign them
to member variables.
In Dart, there's just shorthand.
You see Hug this dot strength.
That just means it's
shorthand for saying,
take this parameter,
and assign it
to my member variable strength.
You can have named constructors.
So you can have a
secondary constructor.
So if you just want a shorthand
for like a super strong bear
hug, just do Hug.bear, and
strength is set to 100.
You can do operator overloading.
This is something that's not
possible in JavaScript today.
This allows you to take two
hugs, and add them together.
And in this class, that means
adding their strength together.
You can have named
optional parameters.
So you don't have to pass
parameters always by the order
that the function
accepts them in.
You can actually provide
names, and make them optional,
and give them default values.
So by default, if I want to
patBack, it's just one hand.
I'm not using both of my hands.
And this is another example
of how terse Dart can be.
Here's toString.
If it's just a
one-line function,
why have a curly brace and
all that extra syntax with it?
You can just do a fat arrow
syntax, that fat arrow says,
return whatever's
on the right of this
is the result of
calling this function.
We also have string
interpolation.
So instead of having to use the
add operator to combine strings
together, or to take a variable
and convert it into a string,
you can actually just use
this dollar sign syntax here.
So if you had a
hug, and you wanted
to print it to the console,
it would be the Embraceometer
reads $strength-- whatever
the value of strength
is at that time.
So one of the most
important things to me
as a developer about Dart
is that the semantics
are really clean.
I come from a C, C++ background,
so coming to JavaScript,
I often get confused.
I don't understand
what's going on.
I compare to things
they shouldn't be equal
and they're equal, or
the other way around.
Dart, that's not going to
happen, because only true
is true.
And there's no undefined.
That doesn't exist.
It's just null.
There's no type coercion.
If I say is a equals
equal to b, the language
is not going to try
and make them equal.
It's just going to evaluate
the equal equals operator,
and return true or false.
That's it.
So what happens if you
try and access some value
on an instance
that doesn't exist?
Well, you actually get a
proper NoSuchMethodError.
The class string doesn't
respond to the missing getter.
And we'll see more on
NoSuchMethod as we go on.
But this is very logical, right?
You asked for the missing
property on a string.
And instead of it
just kind of magically
giving you undefined
or null, you're
getting a proper error
message, telling you
who the receiver was, a little
bit of a message, any arguments
passed to the function.
What about an
index out of range?
This is completely
valid in JavaScript.
You can just ask for this,
you'll get something back.
In Dart, you actually
get a RangeError.
This array does not
have a 99th element,
so it can't possibly
give it to you.
So this stops you from kind of
cruising through development,
not realizing that you've
made a lot of subtle bugs
inside your code.
So this is something
that, for me,
JavaScript is incredibly
confusing, is variable scope.
So we see here that we
have many foos, right?
We have a foo that's
local to the VAR function,
and we have a foo that's
in the global scope.
But there's no hoisting, right?
You can see that the foo
inside the if not true branch
doesn't override the foo
that's in the global scope.
So this kind of operates the
way languages like C and Java
and C# where the scoping
is truly lexical.
And this-- this is like-- every
time I program in JavaScript,
I make this mistake where
I have the this is not
the this that I expect it to be.
But in Dart, it always is the
this that you expect it to be.
So there's a real
scalable structure.
If you want to use
a library in Dart,
you actually have to
explicitly import it,
and you have to
name your libraries.
So everything-- again, there's
a lot of structure here.
So you can see on the
right-hand side of this slide,
I'm making a library.
I'm calling it games.
So if I wanted to
upload it as a package,
you could use my games library.
And my games library
needs the math librarian,
and it needs the
players library,
and there's all these
different classes in there.
But let's dig deeper into
what's new in the Dart language.
So if we look at this,
we see in var button
is equal to new ButtonElements.
We're making a
ButtonElement, and we're
going to insert it into the DOM.
And we want to set
its ID to fancy,
and the text to click, and
add the important CSS class,
and set up a listener for
click, and then finally add it
to the DOM at the end there.
In Dart, we have
this dot dot syntax.
So you could say var button is
equal to a new ButtonElement
dot dot id equals fancy dot
dot text, et cetera, right?
So this saves you
a lot of typing,
and it becomes
clearer that you're
kind of doing all of this
as one unit of logic.
And you can even
go so far as just
put that right inside
the children.add, so you
can do new
ButtonElement dot dot.
So when this expression
is evaluated,
your ButtonElement is
entirely initialized
the way you want it to be, and
then it's added to the DOM.
So what if you wanted to
serialize a hug object?
You wanted to put
it into a data store
somewhere, put it in a database
or something like that,
make it persistable?
You know, in a
class-based language,
you think OK, well, I'll
make a persistable class,
and then have all
the classes that I
want to serialize into this
persistable data store,
and inherit from that.
But that's not really what
object-oriented inheritance
is supposed to be.
So Dart actually has
this concept of a mixin.
So hug is still just inheriting
from the base object,
but you can actually
mix in functionality.
So it doesn't alter
the class hierarchy,
but it provides new
functionality to your class.
So if we have this abstract
class persistable, which
I save load into
JSON, we can say
that class hug extends
object with persistable.
So hug gets the functionality
of the persistable class,
but it doesn't pollute the
class hierarchy in a way
that it is not logically sound.
And then here we say, let's
instantiate a new hug,
and then call save
on it, and it's
going to go into some
database somewhere.
So libraries and JavaScript
interoperability.
So one thing you might
be wondering about Dart
is, OK, it's this new language.
It's running on the web, but can
I use all this JavaScript code
that I already have written?
And the answer is yes.
It's actually relatively
straightforward.
There is a Dart
library that allows you
to proxy between JavaScript
objects and Dart objects,
and pass them back and forth.
So here's a little example.
The Dart code up
here reads like this.
So you get the chartsAPI out
of your JavaScript library.
You create a new
JavaScript array,
and then you create a
new chart by proxying it
through the JS library.
And then you just
call chart.draw.
Now this is actual
JavaScript code
if you were to be writing
JavaScript itself.
You can see that it's
almost identical, aside
from a few extra proxy steps
needed on the Dart side.
So the point here is that
it's very straightforward
to take all of the
legacy code that you've
written in JavaScript, and carry
it with you into the new Dart
land.
So async with callbacks.
We all know how many
callbacks we have,
and they can be kind of scary.
So if we have this catService
here, and we getCatData cute,
and we get the
image ID, and then
we rotate the image by
30 degrees-- I mean,
we're four levels deep with
all this nesting and different
callbacks and so on.
But then you've got to do
all this error handling.
Like what if any one of these
single steps has gone wrong?
You're just repeating
a lot of code here.
So Dart has the
concept of futures,
and you can do a
catService getCat,
and that returns a future.
And then you can just do dot
then and do the next step,
and dot then and
do the next step,
and then dot then
and do the next step.
And the catchError at the end
kind of handles all of them.
So if any one of
these steps fails,
the error case is
going to be executed
at the bottom of the chain here.
So you can actually compose
futures, which is quite nice.
So if you want to get
two different cats,
but you want to do all the logic
only once you have both cats,
you can do this-- you
get two futures back,
and then you call a
future.wait, and pass
in the list of both of them.
And then when that
future will complete,
when they're both completed.
And if any one of
them has an error,
the catchError will
fire at the end.
So asynchronous with
futures-- it's little bit
better than a fiery
housescape that we saw before.
So the streams-- this
is another concept
that is baked into the
core libraries of Dart.
So all of these things
like futures and streams
are not extra
libraries that you go,
and you download, and
you put into your site.
This is part of the
language and the base SDK.
So we're all starting
from a much higher place
than starting from
the blank slate.
So streams are a series
of asynchronous events.
A future is an isolated
asynchronous event.
A stream is a series of them.
So you can think of
streams like bytes
from a file, your messages
from a web socket,
button clicks,
incoming connections.
And basically, all you have
to do to consume things
from a stream is
just this single line
of code at the bottom here,
which is stream.listen.
You're given whatever the
asynchronous event is.
You do something with it.
So let's take a look here.
We have on Element, and there
is a stream for key presses.
Right, so query the DOM.
This is another
nice thing-- query
is just baked in to
the platform like this.
So you have query for
textarea, and then onKeyPress
where the keys are
between 32 and 122.
Map the character code
to a string first.
Right, so this is just going
to first returns the very
first key press.
That's it.
Then print the first character
pressed on the keyboard
is equal to that character.
So web programming with Dart
kind of looks like this.
So you have window.navigator,
getUserMedia,
get the video element.
You can see the dot dot
syntax, the listen, catchError.
XHR requests with
Dart look like this.
It's very straightforward.
Again, you can see how easy
it is to kind of compose
all of the stock Dart
SDK features together
into some really
tight-looking code.
So we have event source
mapping, which is kind of cool.
Like so if you have document
body onClick matches thread.
So listen, and then
print super cool, right?
So this will dynamically-- if
anything on the document that
has the CSS class
thread gets clicked on,
this is going to fire,
even if the element gets
the class later on after
this code is executed,
or is removed its dynamic,
it will just always respect
whichever element has
the dot thread class.
We also have automatic
sanitization.
So if you want to
take some user input,
and put it into the
inner HTML of an element,
it's not possible for them
to insert a script tag,
and run it in there.
Dart actually will
make sure that anything
that is potentially
a security exploit
is removed when you
assigned the inner HTML.
So web components--
we've been talking
a lot about web components,
and Dart fully supports them.
So this is the classic example
of how great components are.
I mean, here is on the
left some variant of Gmail,
and then on the right,
something that logically makes
sense where you have messages,
and message with subject.
I mean, these new
custom elements
really allow you to make kind
of logical and semantic sense
of the tags in your page, rather
than just div and table soup.
There's encapsulation
with custom elements,
so you have structure and
your behavior and styles
can all be hidden inside
of these custom elements.
And they're reusable.
You can just import the library,
and import the HTML file
for the custom
element, and there you
go-- you've got your
own custom element.
There's data bindings
between the DOM nodes.
So polymer.dart kind of
fits in at the foundation
and the core level.
So size and speed-- one
of the goals of Dart--
aside from speed-- is
that we support really
large scale software
development.
Because the language
is so structured,
it's much easier to
make sense of what's
going on in the
editor, actually allows
you to hyperlink through
your source code,
and get to different
functions, and pop around.
It's quite nice.
So by running
faster, you actually
save battery, because when
you're executing your code,
it takes fewer CPU cycles.
So on mobile
devices and laptops,
tablets, et cetera,
running faster actually
will lead to longer battery
life, which is awesome.
We all want that.
So like I said at the
beginning, there's two ways
to run Dart code, right?
You can run Dart in the
Dart virtual machine,
or you can compile
Dart to JavaScript.
And the dart2js compiler
does a really fantastic job
of compiling Dart
code down to JS.
So if we look at
this snippet of code
here where we have var Bob is
equal to new person Bob Smith,
and then we query the
DOM for something,
and then we set the
text of that DOM element
to Bob's first name,
dart2js compiles a code,
and it looks like this.
I mean, it's practically
human readable.
It's, a lot of the time, a
direct one-to-one mapping
between Dart code
and JavaScript code.
So you can also
get minified code.
So at the top here,
we have by default
what dart2js will generate.
And then you can pass
in a flag that says,
OK, compile this,
but also minify it,
and it becomes illegible
like all minified code.
But this, just again,
this helps you save space
when compiling
Dart to JavaScript.
So we also something
built in to the compiler
called tree shaking.
And because Dart
is so structured,
we can actually reason about
what pieces of code are used,
and which pieces of
code are not used.
So even if you import
many, many libraries,
but you only call few
functions, the dart2js compiler
has this phase called tree
shaking, which you just
shake the tree and, all
the stuff falls off of it
that you don't actually need.
And you end up with this really
minimal code right here, which
is that main calls
func2, which calls funcx.
funcy and func1
are never invoked,
so they're not included
in the dart2js output.
The Dart VM-- this is the
project that I work on.
Because Dart is such
strict language,
this actually allows
the virtual machine
to run faster than any
JavaScript virtual machine can.
We went over it a
little bit earlier.
Like, there's real arrays,
there's real classes,
there's directs calls.
There's no, like, walk
up the prototype chain,
find the first object that
can respond to a method,
and invoke it.
The VM will actually
globally track field type.
So if you have class person,
and it has a field called name.
If name is always a string, then
we know it's a string always.
And the VM will
track this, and you
can actually-- when
this was enabled,
we saw kind of
across the board 20%
speed up just from
this one optimization.
So one thing that I actually
personally worked on
was bringing SIMD
to the Dart VM,
and to the web for
the first time.
So this is the CPU die a
dual core ARM processor.
So you can see that the kind of
bluish core area there, that's
like where your integer
arithmetic, your just
general CPU computation occurs.
And then, you can
see VFP, that's
where your floating point,
your double precision numbers
are being executed.
And then we have this
red area here, Neon.
And this is where the SIMD
portion of the CPU is devoted.
So if you look at
how much silicon
is devoted on every CPU-- and
in your laptops and tablets,
there's a ton of silicon devoted
to the SIMD processing, which
up until the Dart VM
added support for SIMD,
it was impossible to tap into.
So you're looking at
maybe 20% of the surface
area of your CPU is
just sitting there idle.
You cannot access
that or program it,
and there's huge performance
gains to be had from being able
to tap into this.
Let me just show you a
demo here to give you
an idea of what's
possible, especially
when it comes to three
games when SIMD is enabled.
So what you're seeing here
is a bunch of monsters
from Doom just kind of
standing around, animating,
doing whatever.
And this application
is attempting
to keep as many monsters
on the screen as possible,
and still run at 60
frames per second.
So there's just this
adaptive algorithm in there.
That's why you see them kind
of popping in and popping out.
We're trying to
keep it about 60.
So right now, SIMD is off.
But if I turn on SIMD,
this is a massive speedup.
I mean, we were
at like about 13,
and now we're in the
high 60s, low 70s.
This is because the
Dart VM actually
lets you tap into that
huge amount of silicon
on your CPU that's specially
designed to accelerate things
like image processing
and 3D graphics.
So I've been talking
about performance a lot,
and we have some publicly
tracked benchmarks.
So internally,
during my games talk,
I talked about how we have
this infrastructure where
we track the
performance across all
of these benchmarks on
every single commit.
And so, these are current
numbers right now.
The green numbers are-- OK,
so first of all, the y-axis,
higher is better.
You're running faster
the higher the bar is.
Green is dart2js.
So we take the Dart
code, we run it
through the dart2js
compiler, and then
we execute it inside Chrome.
Yellow is handwritten
JavaScript.
So some human went out and
wrote the same algorithm
in JavaScript that's
run in Chrome.
The blue bar here
represents the performance
when running under the Dart VM.
So you can see
for DeltaBlue, you
can see that dart2js
actually greatly outperforms
handwritten JavaScript.
And the Dart VM just
destroys all of them.
I mean, it's ridiculously fast.
Richard's dart2js-- so
for Richards and Tracers
dart2js does not do as well
as handwritten JavaScript,
but it does a respectable job.
And then again, you can see
how much faster the Dart
VM is compared to a JavaScript.
And with the Tracer, which
is ray-tracing benchmark,
we're 2.3 times faster than
handwritten JavaScript.
So we also have an NBody, which
is a solar system simulator.
This is another
benchmark that we track.
And this is performance numbers
in Chrome Mobile, so on an ARM
device-- your cell phone running
Chrome with a Dart VM baked
into it.
So we have a handwritten
JavaScript-- yellow here--
and then the light blue
is just the Dart VM.
And we're 1.48 times faster.
You can also port
the NBody benchmark
to take advantage of the
SIMD support in Dart.
And when you do that,
Dart is 2.42 times faster
than handwritten JavaScript.
So Dart is an extremely
structured, kind
of sane language that,
when run under the Dart VM,
can run at least twice as
fast as JavaScript can.
But we really haven't
scratched the surface.
There's so much more
to Dart that we just
don't have time to go
into in this presentation.
Dart has great support
for reflection.
So you could do
things like I want
to iterate over all the
libraries that were imported,
or find a class that responds
to this method, and call it.
There's server-side.
So you all, I'm sure, are
familiar with Node.js,
which runs V8.
So Dart from the get go
has supported the model
of running Dart code on both
the server and the client.
And this really makes code
reuse really straightforward.
You have a bunch
of libraries which
describe the kind of structures
that your application
deals with.
And you can share those
on the server side,
and on the client side.
The pub package manager,
which I mentioned earlier,
which is just like an
integral part of the platform.
We have the editor.
There's built-in support
for unit testing, isolates
for concurrency.
So isolates are kind
of like web workers
where you can farm off work
onto a separate thread,
and pass messages
back and forth.
So I really want to encourage
you all to go out and try Dart.
It's a really exciting language.
I have a hard time
going back to JavaScript
after I've gotten used
to writing in Dart.
And we have a Dartisans
community on G+.
And you can send poll
requests on Github.
Dart is entirely open source.
The VM, the dart2js compiler,
all of the libraries--
everything with
Dart is open source.
We actually have active
external contributors
who are not Google employees.
And I would
encourage anyone here
who is interested
in participating
to join these communities,
get on the mailing list,
start looking at the code,
and feel free to ask questions
on Stack Overflow.
We have a lot of people
that participate there.
So Dart is a stable language,
has stable core libraries,
compiles to JavaScript.
It's relatively evolved compared
to where the web is today.
And we're really
committed to Dart,
and we really want it
to be a huge success.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I
can take questions.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: So here's
two questions.
One is, when will the Dart VM be
merged into Chromium or Chrome?
And the other one is,
what's the opinion
about Dart from other
browsers' vendors?
And how are you going
collaborate with that?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Sure.
We do not have a timeline
for when the Dart
VM will be included in Chrome.
But if you download
the Dart Editor,
it comes with a custom version
of Chrome with a Dart VM baked
into it.
That's what I was running
the monsters demo running on.
So during your development,
you can iterate very quickly
inside what we're Dartium.
And in terms of collaboration
with other browser vendors,
we are an entirely
open source project,
and we openly-- if another
browser vendor wanted
to work with us and incorporate
the VM into their browser,
we would love it.
There would be absolutely
no issue with that.
But again, I just want to
stress that Dart compiles down
to very clean, very
performant JavaScript code.
So in some sense,
it's irrelevant
if other browser vendors do not
include the virtual machine,
because Dart code
compiled to JavaScript
executes very quickly,
in which case,
it's going to run everywhere.
When you deploy a
Dart application,
you're not just deploying
the Dart source code.
You're also deploying the
dart2js source code, as well.
And if your browser happens
to support the Dart VM,
you'll get something that
runs significantly faster.
If it doesn't,
you'll get something
that runs as fast as JavaScript.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: I know
Dart is providing
compiler source for me.
In case that my
[INAUDIBLE] needed
to be protected from
accessing all users.
Does Google have
any official plan
for supporting encryption
or [INAUDIBLE]?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Not
that I'm aware of.
I mean, it's the web.
Source code's out there.
AUDIENCE: But not on VM, right?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Our source code
is running on VM, right?
So why does Google
support [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN MCCUTCHAN:
Yeah, I don't know.
I mean, in some sense,
that's kind of on a tangent,
and not directly
related to Dart.
I mean, maybe you want to
encrypt your JavaScript source
code, and have all JavaScript
engines know how to decrypt it.
But I don't know.
It's certainly not something
we're working on right now.
AUDIENCE: It is an official?
It is official opinion?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's my opinion.
AUDIENCE: All right, thank you.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Other questions?
All right, thanks everyone.
[APPLAUSE]